peu
[Musique]
et pour faire ce reportage sur les
loisirs
j'ai choisi la périphérie de paris c'est
à dire les endroits où c'est difficile
grands ensembles et où entrent ou sur un
minimum de surface maximum de population
donc le maximum de jeunes
alors quel est le problème numéro un
dans cette cité portuaire
quoique c'est l'ennui oui c'est le thème
que vous allez retrouver pendant toute
l'émission ces jeunes s'ennuient et
résultat on les voit au milieu des blocs
se promenait dès qu'ils ont un peu non
libres se promener sur leurs mobylettes
et errer comme ça la grande frayeur de
la population ils sont souvent deux sur
mobile est ce qui est interdit
d'ailleurs il se promène comme ça
gratuitement je veux dire
ils vont d'un endroit à un autre mais
pas forcément deux endroits précis font
le plein au prix moyen de réunir ils
n'ont rien d'autre à faire alors il ya
quand même et des moyens qui sont mis à
leur disposition
mais ils vont vous en parler
[Musique]
quels sont vos
aux distractions dans un grand ensemble
comme celui ci à epinay cinéma maison de
jeunes à les protéger
à part le club là mais il y en a pas
beaucoup qui vont et c'est tout je crois
vous ennuyer ou pas au goût et beaucoup
on a les flippers
vous ne
info des bourses et puis c'est tout on a
rien à faire vous restez jamais avec vos
parents ne soient pas seulement
intéressant ça les croulants
quelle part de l'argent que vous gagnez
vous consacré aux loisirs par exemple
toi tu gagnes combien je gagne à dix
mille francs par semaine à bright 255
j'ai sincèrement tous les jours qu'on a
mangé le midi et mis fin dimanche
et c'est tout bon est ce que tu donnes
tes parents à bruges 2-1 reste ça fait
3000 points de marseille mène il reste
bon il te reste donc combien à peu près
par semaine pour des distractions
mais enfin qu'est ce que tu fais avec ça
tu vas au cinéma ils sont partis du
sanwi sera les dimanches je suis proche
et si on dépense beaucoup de pour les
flippers par exemple trois quarts
il y en a
trois quarts dans les flippers oui elle
aurait cinéma le reste un coup aux
copains ou bien cinéma ya pour assécher
où tu paye toujours
vous êtes en bande là qu'est ce que vous
faites quand vous êtes en bande
on se promène on a eu tout ce que des
bêtises n'ont rarement rarement vous
arrive vous pouvez mettre arbres qu'elle
sort de bêtises
les gens ils se plaignent de ce qu'on
fait du bruit avec les mobylettes les
mobylettes comment vous voulez être
payés nous aussi
rien rien rien à crédit oui on est en
train d'y affronter être mécanicien
je prends tellement de loisirs le soir
quand les 9 heures à l'école puisque
ball comprendre dans l'école j'étais si
on choisit rejet le samedi le dimanche
et des copains c'est tout le flipper
du coup tu vas faire vite
[Musique]
ce soir avec vos parents pourquoi tu me
passes a toujours des discussions et non
s'accordent pour ce n'est pas pareil on
n'a pas les mêmes idées alors par
exemple qu'est-ce que tu as comme idée
n'a pas ton père bachet pour moi je dis
j'aurais bien passé mon permis aux
règles comme samedi note encore trop
jeune mois à ton âge pour de voiture je
faisais la guerre le truc comme ça alors
alors que ce soit comme distraction
qu'est-ce que tu as comme loisirs ont
fait flipper
en fait finalement vous vous ennuyez oui
si on y va
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
est-ce qu il s'ennuierait - à votre avis
le repos demain s'il habitait dans un
vieux quartier de paris je crois oui
parce que vous allez voir on a on a
tourné ensuite à la courneuve le moins
qu'on puisse dire de ces grands
ensembles c'est qu'il manque d'âme on a
construit on a paré au plus pressé et le
problème des loisirs de ces jeunes a été
un peu vont pas la dernière roue du
carrosse on n'a pas tellement eu le
temps jusqu'à présent d'y penser et tout
de même c'est plus clair c'est les
appartements sont beaucoup plus vastes
alors qu'est ce qui manque
bah il manque d'abord d'une part des
maisons des jeunes la culture ici à la
courneuve
les deux premiers commerces qui se sont
installés ce sont deux cafés café où on
trouve les fameux flipper de vous
entendez parler souvent dans cette
émission
[Musique]
le second jeune la maison des jeunes le
gros oeuvre est terminé mais pour qu'on
puisse aménager l'intérieur on attend un
feu vert préfectoral qui tarde peut-être
un peu à venir depuis depuis quelques
mois la nouvelle préfecture d'ailleurs
qu'il doit sa saveur cette région
parisienne avait envisagé un certain
moment d'y installer ses services
administratifs mais je crois que le
projet a été abandonné
mais en attendant elle a pour l'heure il
n'y a pas de maison des jeunes voyez la
voix si elle n'est pas en service n'ont
absolument pas
alors comme ils n'ont rien à faire
qu'est ce qu'ils font ils s'ennuient et
ils sont livrés oisiveté se promène le
soir dans le centre commercial ils ont
suivi d'ailleurs caméra sur l'épaule
droite ces garçons aux années lamu
aucune région
puis café toujours café banane si ça va
bien moment mais après
mais non je ne sais pas question de
seine c'est parti pour un jeune le café
c'est bien beau venir
[Musique]
non jours
tiens une distraction sa fête annuelle
30 tirs
tu écris valable car le vin pour
raconter
quand
ça va faire
là
vous faites
c'est un rebelle john terry dit comme ça
que tu veux faire un carton j'avais
mozilla milieu
[Musique]
parlons nous
voilà
[Musique]
en définitive comme personne ne résout
le problème de leurs loisirs au niveau
où ils le souhaitent les jeunes essaient
de les organiser leurs loisirs comme ils
peuvent
et en l'occurrence qu'ils organisent
dans la cave oui ils ont pu utiliser à
la courneuve des locaux qui étaient
auparavant je crois des garages pour
vélos et ils les ont transformés en un
local décoré d'ailleurs pas agréable et
c'est là qu'ils se réunissent le samedi
le dimanche pour danser car promise
organisent eux mêmes leurs loisirs les
organise selon leur désir n'est pas
question bien entendu de loisirs
intellectuelle alors ils sont là
évidence mais quand ils prennent une
initiative c'est à ce seul niveau
exactement
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et
il
[Musique]
en en regardant ces images n'a pas
l'impression que c'est tellement comme
on la lit trop souvent la violence ou
l'érotisme qu'à rechercher plutôt la
solidarité c'est le fait d'être ensemble
oui je crois que le problème des loisirs
des jeunes c'est un problème de
regroupements ils ont besoin de se
regrouper entre eux ils n'aiment pas
être seul il n'aime pas tellement
finalement rester avec leurs parents
[Musique]
bonjour
lens est en fait dans la bande
il arrive le mieux à vaincre cet ennui
d'entre eux parlé au début oui la bande
pas tellement sur ce genre at-il vous
venez souvent surprise party comme ça
quand même tous les combien ce n'est pas
maintenant alors le samedi je travaille
je ne me permet pas de venir
je suis secrétaire médicale puis je fais
j'apprends le métier de manipulatrice
jeu sans fin du log et à part ces
surfaces parti qu'est ce que vous avez
comme autres distractions sont le cinéma
l'enfant premier les danses à huy est ce
qu'ils pensaient qu'on s'occupe
suffisamment des loisirs des jeunes dans
les grands ensembles
j'en pense pas lents sont plutôt les
jeunes qui essaient de savoir j'ai
quelque chose de trop mal je vois que
les croiser personne ne s'en occupe pas
contre fc c'est vous qui voulait
organiser entre copains oui oui oui on a
fait tout notre possible pour voir sur
retrouver le sale boulot dimanche parce
que ses seuls français pour se voir les
autres figurants travail dgt
[Musique]